بالعوده الى تلميح الرئيس الروسي بانشاء
منطقه عازله داخل اوكرانيا في حال استمرت
الهجمات على مناطق روسيه هنا نلقي نظره
اقرب على ما يجري سواء على الحدود او في
العمق الروسي اكثر المقاطعات الروسيه
تضررا هي
تقابلها في الاوكرانيه وهي تتعرض اما
للقصف او للتسلل من قبل مجموعات تقول انها
روسيه معارضه لسياسه موسكو لتشعل بعض
النقاط في المقاطعه وتاخذ احيانا بعض
الرهان ليست بالورود وحدها هناك ايضا كورس
كالمجاوره وبريان ايضا تتعرضان ايضا
للاستهداف بقصف او هجمات
لتوغل بريا هناك كذلك يتعرض تعرضت
وهي غربيه البلاد تعرضت لهجوم ممن وصفتهم
موسكو بالمخربين الاوكرانيين على محطتين
نوويتين استهدف هجوم مسيرتين ملغمتين محطه
لتكرير النفط في منطقه بيسكوف وهي التي
تمد خط دروجبا الضخم الذي ينقل النفط
الخام من سيبيريا الى اوروبا كما تعرض
مطران عسكريان للاستهداف في منطقه ريازان
وساراتوف على بعد مئات الكيلومترات من
ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا العاصمه الروسيه
نفسها موسكو تعرضت هي الاخرى لاكثر من مره
لهجوم بطائرات مسيره وهي هجمات تنفيك
دائما المسؤوليه عنها هذه التصريحات من
جانب بوتين تثير اسئله عده بشان امكانيه
فردي منطقه عازله في اراض تحتلها روسيا
بالفعل داخل اوكرانيا ولا تسيطر عليها
بالكامل بحكم التطورات الميدانيه لكن
لنعرف اولا ما هي المناطق العازله التي
تسمى احيانا بالامنه
هي مساحه في بلد ما تحددها الامم المتحده
من اجل توفير الحمايه للسكان المدنيين
ويكون ذلك في حالات الحروب والصراعات
الداخليه كما تقام مثل هذه المناطق على
حدود دولتين
متجاورتين يوجد بينهما نزاع او خلاف من
الناحيه القانونيه يقع جزء من المنطقه
العازله على اراضي الدوله الاولى الجزء
الاخر على اراضي الدوله الثانيه ومن
الضروري ان يتوفر حظر جوي لحمايه هذه
المنطقه العازله وذلك لا يتحقق الا
بموافقه من مجلس الامن الدولي متابعه لهذا
الموضوع معنا من عمان لواء فايزه الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك حضره اللواء
هل من الممكن عمليا انشاء منطقه عازله بين
روسيا واوكرانيا في ظل المعطيات التي
نعرفها جميعا
يعني هناك ثلاثه تصريحات من ثلاثه مسؤولين
اولا الرئيس الاسبق اعتبر ان المنطقه
العازل يجب ان تكون الحدود البولنديه اي
بمعنى اخر ان اوكرانيا كامله يجب ان تكون
منطقه عازله احد اعضاء الدوما في هذا
اليوم صرح بان عمق المنطقه العاجل يجب ان
يكون ثلاث مئه كيلو متر وهذا سيكون الى
غرب نهر الدنيا
والتصريح الرئيس بوتين مرتبط بمدايات
الاسلحه
وبالتالي يعني هناك ثلاثه تصريحات بثلاثه
ابعاد الجغرافيه من منظور الواقع اعتقد ان
الوقت الان لا يمكن روسيا من انشاء منطقه
عازله وفقا للمفهوم الروسي وليس لمفهوم
القانون الدولي لماذا لان القوات الروسيه
هي الان المدافعه نعم هي تهاجم في بعض
المناطق لكن القوات المتعرضه هي الق
الاوكرانيه وهي تصرح صراحه على الصعيد
العسكري والسياسي انها تسعى لاستعاده
الاراضي الاوكراني المحتله اذا من منظور
واقعي لا تملك روسيا القدره حاليا على
ترجمه هذه التصريحات الى واقع ملموس هل
هناك ايضا تناقض بين دعوه موسكو لمنطقه
عازله ورغبتها الدائمه في اوكرانيا منزوعه
السلاح لان المساله ايضا بها بعض التناقض
يا سيدي يعني التصريحات متباينه وانت عشرت
يعني كانت التصريحات ليست تصريح الاول
للرئيس بوتين حول مجازا تعريف المنطقه
العازله او ما يقصده بالمنطقه العازله او
المنطقه الفاصله حسب التعريف القانوني لكن
الان هو تحدث في هذا اليوم
من ضمن الشروط السته التي وضعت وتحدث عنها
خلال ال 48 ساعه الماضيه هو يتحدث عن
منسوعه السلاح اليوم اشاره صراحه الى انها
لم تعد تملك الكثير من الاسلحه الذاتيه
ذات من خلال التصنيع وانما ما تملكه من
الاسلحه التي تاتي بها تاتيها من الغرب
وهو صرح ان احد البنود السته من وجهه نظره
لانهاء الصراع القائم توقف امداد السلاح
الغربي اي بمعنى اخر ان تكون اوكرانيا
محايده اوكرانيا خارج النيتو اوكرانيا
منزوعه السلاح اوكرانيا بدون الكتائب
النازيه ولكن ايضا
سيد اللواء اي اي منطقه عازله تاتي بترتيب
دولي
بقرار من مجلس الامن عاده هذه مساله تكون
مستحيله الان في ظل احتلال روسي للزامل من
اوكرانيا
سيدي انا قلت لك المنطقه العازله من منظور
روسي وليس من منظور التعريف الدولي عندما
نتحدث عن المنطقه العازله اما تكون داخل
حدود الدوله او تكون بين دولتين داخل
الحدود الدوله في حاله الصراع الداخلي كما
نشا في سوريا والمطالبه التركيه بانشاء
منطقه عازله منطقه عازله عندما تكون بين
دولتين كما هو بين كوريا الشماليه وكوريا
الجنوبيه او بين العراق والكويت بعد غزو
بعد انسحاب العراق وحرب
1991 في الواقع الحالي اذا تحدثنا وفقا
لمفهوم القانون التعريف القانون الدولي
للمنطقه العازله يجب ان تكون جزء من اراضي
روسيا وجزء من اراضي اوكرانيا علما ان
الاراضي التي تحتلها روسيا لا تعترف الامم
المتحده اراضي روسيه اذا يجب ان تكون جزء
من الجغرافيا الروسيه المعترف بها دوليا
شكرا لك فايز الدويري من عمان